alors bonjour de la planète
ici l'équipe de tam-tam canada vous avez
l'air un peu fait j'ai menacé les deux
bras bonjour alors c'est tam-tam kanata
l'émission qui est un petit nom aussi ça
s'appelle bonjour la planète c'est
mondialement connu nous on travaille de
montréal en direct 11h11 c'est notre
heure après les bulletins de nouvelles
on s'est dit il ya de la place pour le
direct sur le web sur toutes les
plateformes facebook youtube et on en
oublie
il y en a certains qu'on veut pas
mentionné que mercy même la crc iranien
oui oui c'est la meilleure en europe
nous regarder oui cet auteur chaque
histoire que de quoi on parle aussi
alors qu'ils parlent en ce moment - oui
au hockey c'est oublier l'autre jour
quel âge avait ça m'a pris je pense
alors chantal et animale et chantal jean
d'esme bonjour bonjour
ce sont des collègues de r6 qui sont
avec nous comme d'habitude il ya aussi
les hô chi minh au qui de retour de
vacances bonjour les eaux il est capable
de tout faire est capable de faire la
technique en plus de faire de votre
travail
tous les cuisses champions lui fait ça
dans plusieurs langues aussi mais reste
là bas puis les chinois c'est vrai à
bientôt allons diffuser ans et on leur
explique que parce que déjà que son
nouveau nom on diffuse tous les
vendredis en cinq langues même dessin
comme officielles du canada hockey
est-ce que vous êtes prêts pour le sujet
cette semaine
oui peut-être peut-être vous savez
comment on devine le sujet de la semaine
non
un ideo bien vidéo nommée à un ou une
vidéo et la boule magique qui roule
vous savez c'est soit spectacles publics
alors vidéo mais avec des images cinq
images
ah ouais d'accord votre vidéo vous la
voyez comme les autres internautes à
travers le monde entier premières images
ou me dit de tel que vous avez une idée
du sujet qu'est-ce qu'on aperçoit
commence bien sur la piste deuxième
image
qu'est-ce qu'on aperçoit alexis rappelle
à l'anglais la canadienne nash de
l'exception vous pensez ou troisième
image qu est ce qu on voit déjà un
cinéma cinémas quatrième image ça passe
vite
vous avez pas encore de serre les chutes
niagara les feux d'artifice alors de
quoi parle aujourd'hui des deux
touristes anta diop
ok les chutes du niagara mais on y va
faire du tout ça c'était le cliff tonéo
à niagara on situ toronto où se situent
les chutes toronto site en eau les
chutes c'est un bas c'est à 60 km de
distance je pense au maximum donc les
gens qui vont à toronto vont forcément
aux chutes du niagara pour visiter la
justice accuse le côté américain c'est
voilà et de l'autre côté de l'étang du
dos tout petit c'est le coin canadien le
coin canadien canadien là on voit les
chutes
d'accord c'est l'étude canadienne c'est
beaucoup plus beau que celle des états
unis bien sûr et la toute petite chute
des petites chutes américaines tout
petit tout petit tout petit et est là
voici les chutes qui sont scellées côté
américain si vous pensez oui oui vous
connaissez ça vous avez raison c'est sa
pensée à l'arctique aussi un oui début
janvier
c'était tout gelé par pas complètement
sa circulaire
jeune canadien vu d'en haut je sais
combien de fois où celle du niagara
j'ai vécu sa jeunesse la voix rend
pratiquement à oui c'est votre coin
toronto lundi comment ça se fait que
vous parlez français baissent parce que
les dm indien et puis il ya des
francophones en ontario mais puis sur
l'a6 sur wii
ailleurs ce qui est amusant c'est que
vous êtes en ontario sur le taux de 400
qui mène vers le québec
il vous parle dans les deux langues
officielles attention de cinq minutes de
délai ou qui ont des trous dans la
chaussée
mais quand vous excellence du canada
c'est ça mais quand vous travaillez du
côté du québec c'est seulement en
français seulement en france parce qu a
pas de touristes évidemment puis les
anglophones qui habite au québec qui
comptera français alors ça dépend de
quel endroit où j'habite à l'ouest de
l'île
oui mais là toutes les pannes ont ces
arrêts comme en espagnol d'accord le
disco paris au mexique
jockin des voyages au mexique c'est fini
entre eux c'est la diversité du canada
fait sens et en france c'est quoi je
sais tout je pense que c'est stop c'est
ce qu'ils ont fait une enquête près
sérieuses ont pas demandé aux hauts
responsables québécois mise au linguiste
est-ce que ce tapis arrêt c'est la même
chose on dit en fait le mot arrêt est un
non sens c'est le mot stop jeudi c'est
un anglicisme en français vous pensez
vous devrez faire un article là dessus
la semaine prochaine mais oui je pense
que ça pourrait être intéressant ce que
je vais le faire mais on va se battre on
peut le faire ensemble
aujourd'hui on fait diversion à ça et
j'ai ma première question pour vous au
jeu des grosses boules la bouffe ainsi
que d'accord alors c'est bon pot premier
point ya trois manches points
ça c'est facile aujourd'hui on va donner
des points mais léo va tout rafler comme
d'habitude
bah oui raison de plus pour gagner parce
qu'on a la tête encore toute fraîche
voulez vous la question où les saisies
voici la question
les chutes du niagara sont très larges
ce qu'on fait on l'a vu avec un débit de
plus de 2800 mètres cubes à la seconde
c'est beaucoup plus que dans votre
baignoire elles sont les chutes les plus
puissantes d'amérique du nord
voilà pour le préambule maintenant la
question vrai ou faux
ces chutes ont déjà cessé de couler
complètement ces chutes ont déjà cessé
de couler complètement allaitement vrai
ou faux
une des chutes qui cesse de couler
complètement vous paraît vraisemblable
c'est faux et je suis bien content
qu'ils aient pas imiter ici donc c'est
faux c'est vrai marc vous trancher c'est
vrai une fois dans l'histoire c'est faux
c'est vrai c'est en partie deux fois
dans l'histoire alors virer natif du
coin vous avez tous raison parce que
complètement
oui une fois partiellement oui une fois
et deux fois en bonne partie des cheveux
foncés de couler je vais vous avez
raison une fois complètement dans les
soirs ce soir c'est vous qui avez le
plus raison mais je trouve ça assez
curieux 21 mois combien le vin tout le
monde à vin encore parfait alors à semer
27 29 mars 1948 et eu un embâcle à eau
des chutes
c'est un lac qui amène l'eau des chemins
qui mènent aux chutes voilà et il ya eu
un bac c'est le printemps
pleins de glace et pendant deux jours
tout était bloqué si bien que les
américains les canadiens sont allés se
promener dans l'eee des chutes ramasser
des objets ils ont trouvé des anciens
fusil de là je me rappelais plus de
quelle guerre et vestiges
ça c'est pour la fois où ça s'est arrêté
complètement et la fois où ça s'est
arrêté en partie devront regarder la
vidéo numéro deux c'est assez récent ça
date
pour ceux qui ont imaginé peu près
50 ans c'est pratiquement d'histoire
connu 1969
regardez ça ça c'est l'échec du côté
américain aucun de ses tubes et puis
voilà donc on les voit scc sont des
ingénieurs l'armée américaine qui ils
ont arrêté le passage des chutes ils ont
envoyé l'eau vers les chutes canadienne
aujourd'hui vous pouvez bien les prendre
quelques jours des versions parce qu'ils
ont dû rebâtir solidifier les chutes le
là parce que elle s'effrite et ont
rapidement et l'esca de perdre leur
chute complètement au détriment du
canada remportait la palme des plus bel
endroit pour visiter les chutes ce qui
est toujours le cas a remarqué ils ont
stoppé la l'érosion de façon unilatérale
ils ont quand même demander l'avis du
canada pour le jeu ça se fait avec
l'accord des deux plutôt rassurant vu
que c'est la frontière les deux os mais
oui regardez comme c'est quelque chose
ils ont complètement arrêté ça pendant
quelques jours pour mettre du ciment
pour refaire la un endroit qui qui
s'érode il paraît que dans trois cent
mille ans peut-être même moins les
chutes seront complètement disparu et
aux hautes et elles ont vu elles sont
nées il ya environ trois cent mille
quatre cent mille ans moi je suis pas un
expert soul et on va aller vers
quelqu'un qui s'y connaît un peu plus ce
qui nous attend une invitée spéciale une
invité mystère on va dire cette semaine
donc que vous devez deviner qui s est
invité et ce qu'elles ajoutent à l'eau
dans notre émission aujourd'hui il
s'agit de nathalie préseau bonjour
nathalie une équipe de petits comiques
ils peuvent seulement vous pouvez
dépendre par ou pardon par plus si vous
voulez un hosto choix vous fait dire et
faire durer le plaisir aussi longtemps
que vous le voulez mais c'est à eux de
deviner qui vous êtes et ce que vous
ajoutez à l'émission aujourd'hui va
commencer avec alice alice alesi poser
une question alors comment ça se fait
que des chutes comme celle qu'on a
regardé tantôt puisse disparaître au fil
des ans pour d'école parce que on a
déterminé que vous étiez pas géologue
d'accord non
c'est que celle à l'érosion habituel
alors il semble que j'ai entendu dire un
pied par par année mais donc contenir
comme on dit ici alors un tiers de moins
par année
qui est cette dame est ce que vous êtes
professeur ou enseignante
non ok vous travaillez pour le
gouvernement ou non oui je mets des
taxes est le salaire est légaliste
regarder les livres qui se trouve
derrière nous est un auteur à bien y
regarder elle et elle est surpris par
votre science et urbaniste c'est oui à
la réponse est oui l'image affiche un
petit peu ouais ouais mais on vous
entend bien d'accord alors oui c'est une
auteure et puis en fait de à mon compte
de plusieurs guides je suis j'aime
beaucoup
vous vous disiez les sk des français
d'abord je vous annonce tuque un site
touristique est en train de se faire que
si j'ai une amie qui travaille là-dessus
s'appelle bonjour niagara
vous vous êtes auteur de travaux log non
affiche une auteure de livres publiés
papier et puis en fait la raison pour
les pièces d'équipement comment
contacter c'est parce que je viens de
faire pour unissent la maison d'édition
québécoise une révision de leurs
éditions toronto niagara en passant les
gens des choses dont je vais parler les
gens peuvent simplement aller sur le
système de la maison d'édition ulysse et
ils peuvent acheter un shérif seulement
pour les dollars s'ils veulent en
version en ligne
je trouve qu'elle sait peut-être pas
très bonnes annonces et puis nous on va
offrir gratuitement vos photos d'accord
vous vous chargez d'une facture pas au
regard des cds et les photos que nous
avons envoyé pour nous montrer que
vraiment il ya bien sûr les chutes mais
il l'intérêt de connaître aussi les
zones touristiques n'ont foulé par les
pieds le barça ne connaît pratiquement
ou très peu de gens les connaissent et à
travers ces photos on va découvrir un
peu plus cette belle région du niagara
très proche de toronto alors l'heure
est ce que vous voyez l'image où il faut
vous décrire mais si c'est ce que vous
voyez on voit des personnes qui
s'étaient les saleuses rue dans ma part
laine et oui mon wieland
c'est ce que l'ontario a de plus
américaine on est dedans et c'est là que
ça lui puisque les blablas ligne et en
forme de coeur les lunes de miel que
kate chez tous à tout et kitsch lab sur
cette rue l'oeil et aux alentours sa
garantie mais c'est ça aussi la turquie
est tellement pauvre kitsch alors on
allie le meilleur des deux mondes
différents sans jamais aller avec ça
c'est vrai je pense qu'il ya sept
ketchup et juste à côté c'est le parc
qui est magnifique on va regarder en
arrière
on a regardé les images je suis à côté
voilà ça c'est des choses les chutes on
connaît ça regardez là la nature ya un
sentier comme sa démarche à travers la
falaise est entourée de verdure
c'est ce qui se passe et les photos que
vous voyez ce qui se passe c'est que les
gens premièrement la raison pour
laquelle on a des chutes c'est parce que
le lac érié inné de l'eau qui tombe vers
le lac ontario
il ya une grande brisure qui s'appelle
l'escarpement et quand parler de la
région du niagara
c'est en fait l'escarpement les
merveilles de l'escarpement alors la
rivière niagara quand elle est cool
c'est d'une puissance incroyable
effectivement le switch côté canadien
mais lorsque vous allez environ 15
minutes en voiture plus plus beau vous
pouvez aller sur le bord de cette
rivière il est tellement profonde qui a
une énergie on sent l'énergie adhésion
dans l'air c'est du spectacle
il ya deux façons d'en profiter c'est la
façon dont ppr avec un ascenseur c'est
le white white world work on peut
prendre l'ascenseur est allé il ya un
bon bouaké donc on peut vraiment on est
deux on voit les taurillons c'est
merveilleux mais si ceux qui ont des
bonnes jambes peuvent aller gratuitement
au nord à new york donc tout à l'heure
quand envoyer des photos ça c'est
gratuit on descend quatre étages
d'escaliers puis là
on a plusieurs sentir chez eux c'est
extraordinaire je suis allé vite des
adolescents blasé et qu'ils percent
s'ennuyait et on peut voir des jets
boats en bas il ya des écluses aussi là
où passe le trafic maritime
oui alors ça c'est donc la rivière
niagara mais il ya une autre façon de
relier le lac érié à au lac ontario se
sont laissé le canal wilde et six à sept
écluses et les gens oublient dalila et
c'est tout près de niagara
c'est extraordinaire l'éclusé numéro 3 a
été aménagé les coins musée puis on peut
on peut les observer
il ya un tableau qui nous dit quand est
ce que le prochain navire arrive pour
convaincre rien c'est un processus
extraordinaire pour les petits et les
grands
mais les cluses numéro il explique le
numéro quatre chemins je vois toujours
confirmé le tout à l'heure il ya une
écluse convient les services en français
parfois c'est juste un peu plus loin en
temps dans la vie alors au sujet de la
langue je dois vous avouer que moi j'ai
eu beaucoup de conversations cette
semaine avec des responsables du parc et
que j'ai un peu surpris de voir que le
niveau de français je parle pas de la
qualité mais du delà de la quantité
niveau est pas aussi élevé que ce que
pas loin des chutes ne lève pas au point
suivant j'ai trouvé ça un petit peu
choquant plus de français si vous parlez
du service touristique de niagara les
francophones sont d'accord avec vous et
c'est pour ça qu'ils sont en train de se
regrouper pour faire le site bonjour
niagara pointant justement il ya des
grosses lacunes mais partout dans les
grands services tout en ontario sauf
dans la région d'ottawa très souvent
c'est difficile même si on dit que c'est
vilain c'est un peu difficile de trouver
une personne qui va me répondre au
téléphone mais comme on plie de toronto
et très bonne course et l ai parlé
tantôt de certains endroits qui sont
moins connus du public
est ce que c'est parce qu'il ya une
déficit de communication vous parliez
des écluses numéro 3 numéro 4 que les
gens ne connaissent pas pratiquement non
c'est que je pense qu'il ya
malheureusement beaucoup de gens qui
travaillent
moi j'aime beaucoup développés se lève
la bonne mentalité ex touristes alors
j'aime qu'on soit touriste dans sa
propre ville le bon touriste en vidéo
laure et le tourisme soit intéressant à
mon sens veut que seulement cocher des
choses sur sa liste alors on veut aller
sur la route lecture on veut aller dans
les chutes on veut probablement aller en
bateau puis probablement je sais pas
faire un tour de james bond mais par
contre on parle moins des choses qui
sont moins de la table comme par exemple
journée bahreïn the world
alors voir les chutes au besoin de faire
le bateau si on prend il ya une espèce
de tunnel qui nous emmène derrière les
chutes
c'est fantastique une expérience a pour
toute la famille expo
et puis m comme je dis les gens vont
très rarement aller plus bas que licht
alors oui on voit actuellement les
images des vignobles c'était là il faut
souligner le fait que dia grand stade
est seul endroit où on produit des vins
des quantités et son excellente aussi
c'est un microclimat ses seins de ces
seuils d'ailleurs tout à l'heure on
parlait de 60 kilomètres séparant km
mais ça prend une heure et demie pour
conduire de toronto et niagara
mais un mets venus nous t'avons niagara
gagna garrandaux lake et ça c'est
l'endroit pour aller pour les amateurs
de vin et un festival de théâtre ne
chauffe estivants qui explique en partie
d'année mais c'est les vignobles ont pu
visiter on peut déguster et je lis parce
que vous êtes vous dit
une heure et demie en auto djallit
complètement son ouais parce que parfois
le trafic est très aisé 60 km de toronto
fois beaucoup plus de noirs à cause du
trafic était très intense
moi j'ai dit 60 ça c'est de mémoire de
l'an dernier au mois de juin après midi
a pas de circulation du tout ça est
l'événement
mais je vais vous demander quelque chose
je pense que j'ai pas réponse à cette
question je suis pas comme un avocat je
pose pas des questions auxquelles je
répondrai
je skie pas un aspect historique entre
les etats unis canada dans cette région
là des batailles c'est un endroit là où
géographiquement on était très
rapprochés d'un drone américain aura pu
nous envoyer des des boulets de canon
tirés de l'autre côté de la rivière très
facilement est ce qu'ils ont ils ont été
tentés de le faire
est ce qu'un aspect historique militaire
à toute cette région
encore une fois on savait dessine moi
parce que je suis passé du problème
c'est un prénom
on a perdu juste quelques secondes la
communication c'était sans doute un daaf
un effet des américains
comment s'appelait exactement sur cet
endroit où on peut avoir plus
d'informations sur les offensives
militaires américaines le fort erie fort
et très bien vous faire une recherche là
dessus je pense que vous avez raison
tout à fait les américains fort érié
sommes dit que c'est la guerre 18 12 12
la fois où ils ont tenté d'envahir le
canada y d'une bataille landis line et
la saulaie général broc qui est tombé
sous les balles des américains c'est
ryan monument pour john rockefeller est
à ce moment là que les canadiens sont
allés brûler washington a exercé durant
cette guerre
oui en fait c'est pour ça que ça
s'appelle le white house parce que les
canadiens à washington puis ont brûlé la
maison de président ah bon c'est bien
ils se sont pas laissés faire pour
éviter les invités un historien très
faible dans les faits mais si je perds
mais comme je dis ça c'est une révision
moi c'est surtout j'ai fait énormément
de refait tous les pays pour visiter
toronto je me suis assuré que les
attractions étaient vraiment à jour par
contre ce guide leurs efforts au niveau
de l'histoire
voilà une première partie de l'histoire
qui a pas été écrite par mois qu'elle
est écrit par plusieurs personnes avant
moi et je dois dire que j'ai appris
énormément de choses que j'ai retenu
rien parce que
mais c'est une très forte composante du
bief du liste pour toronto alors et
c'est toute la région de ses biens
guidant le français et en anglais
c'est un guide en français seulement en
français sur le manquer et en parlant d
origine de la région pour monter avant
les américains et les iroquois je pense
c'est leur territoire oui et d'ailleurs
il ya énormément d'informations aussi
sur toute cette situation là et puis une
anecdote intéressante
il y avait le beau parc de où je vous
envoie sur le bord de la rivière pendant
longtemps il ya eu une forêt des totems
qui était la fête par une heure par un
japonais est allé aux voix émue et il y
avait des soldats plein soldats de la
guerre de 12,18 d'eau du tout et parce
que c'est ça a été jugée comme une
appropriation culturel alors tous les
totems ont été enlevés alors ce midi
d'hier on est vraiment dans ces secteurs
là il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
discussions que ce fait j'ai pas le
nombre de duparc mais il ya un parcours
on vient de faire de très beaux
monuments pour les autochtones tels que
raconter ça ressemble à du pillage
ça me semble à du pillage de ressources
culturelles le nom c'était c'était
quelque chose d'assez amusant pour tout
le monde parce que c'était très rigolo
mais le fait d'utiliser le totem ça peut
passer
donc c'est comme ça que les choses se
passent aujourd'hui tout est nathalie
vous nous rappeler le nom de votre votre
guide
alors le guide de la maison du lys moi
j'en ai d'autres et les chutes du
niagara
et puis c'est ça c'est en ce moment
disponible en ligne où vous pouvez
l'acheter sur le site directement en
papier c'est en français donc s'il veut
rejoindre nathalie pour lui bander plus
de questions sur l'histoire des chutes
vous la joindre
l'express l'hebdomadaire express à
toronto merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté
l'invitation cette semaine vers seuil et
nathalie réseau qui est à toronto
alors comme ça ça jam sur les autoroutes
sujet bien qu des fois oui
a pas grand chose pour causer une grande
claque 10 mars un bouchon pour tout
comme on vient d'ailleurs de votre
question les chutes vont disparaître
parce que mais c'est effrayant parce
qu'avec les lotions les chutes de kull
chaque année je me dis il y à des
millions d'années les chutes étaient à
niague randall hic son recul et le
quilit-quilit jusqu'à la place
maintenant puis éventuellement ils vont
reculer jusque là qu il y ait un couple
éclate aux sceptiques de tout ça non
mais non ça n'a rien à voir non mais
région et écrire est creusée par des par
le glacier avec l'acier ça c'est une
histoire climatique j'en conviens et
pour ce qui est du retrait des chutes
n'ont invité un géologue qui est
magnifique c'est quand vous descendez
jusqu'à jusque dans la rivière aube au
delà de wierre dans la gorge qu'on
appelle ça c'est c'est incroyable c'est
comme descendants un autre monde
complètement fou ce qui me regarde les
images on présente enfin les images des
chutes moi j'attendais depuis deux
heures
allez voir et louis ce qui étonne quand
on est dans la gorge des séquences
cultes et juste la rivière est là avec
toute cette puissance l'asm se planquer
pas des personnes qui tombent denain
parce que des fois les gens sont paul
très attentif
j'étais inutilisés quand je suis sur le
côté jeté trois fois la dernière fois
c'était les derniers tu te places la
houle à l'eau tombe de juste avant et
c'est moi je suis nos petits zay par la
cour par cette force de l'eau pu
effectivement simple peu à necker
lorsqu'on est agrippé la com com l ai
dit tantôt il ya des tunnels qui vont en
arrière tu échoues essai c'est
incroyable de voir la lettone et les
tonnes d'eau qui tombent devant vous
et avec l'ionisation dallaire c'est
spécial ouais vous êtes déjà allé au chu
thalys non non j'ai la chance d'avoir
été les deux chutes plus grands de la
musique dès qu'il pleut c'est les chutes
du niagara
les chutes d'iguaçu a missionné en
argentine au nord de l'argens il voit
souvent c'est extraordinaire c'est de
l'ampleur des chutes d'iguaçu oui mais
c'est plus haut plus haut c'est pas
comme ça screen dix ans c'est vraiment
plus haut s'est extasié jeu mais j'ai vu
des images en faisant cette recherche
sur niagara j'ai vu des images de lui je
vais pas penser les inclure on va parler
d'eux d'autres chutes dans un instinct
comparable aux chutes du niagara offert
le tour du monopole on voit s'amuser on
apprendre sur les autres pays cependant
quand on regarde ces images êtes vous
prêt pour la deuxième manche de notre
jeu questionnaire
ça vaut pour combien de points cette
deuxième manche 30 points 30 points
félicitations vous gagnez c'était la
question
bon voici alors en octobre 1829 sam
patch écoutez bien là ça va faire partie
de la question par exemple
ce patch qui se faisait appeler le
sauteur yankees a sauté dans la chute du
fer à cheval donc la chute canadienne et
il est devenu la première personne à
survivre un plongeon par les chutes
depuis il ya eu aussi un exploit en 1901
de madame à niteroi a été la première
personne est aussi la première femme à
descendre des chutes en tonneau les
sorti quasiment indemne de la chute
juste un petit problème au bas du dos et
depuis madame terreur et son exploit 901
dites moi combien de personnes se sont
jetés du haut des chutes combien de
personnes se sont jetés du haut des
chutes
la personne qui est le plus proche de la
bonne réponse remporte les 30 points
volontairement ou par accident
volontairement oui parce qu'il ya des
codes and accidentelle mortelle de
criminels non non non déjà qu'ils ont
volontairement personnes oui
[Musique]
56 56 bien s'étendre aux droits
populaires dont 56 56 personnes ont
tenté l'expérience depuis 1901
alice et j'irai avec beaucoup moins que
ça parce que c'est pas une expérience
tentante ça fait peur
j'irai peut-être avait que 5 ou 10 5 ou
10 mais il faut choisir à ses 5 ou 6 10
peut-être cinq peut-être cinq avoue marc
quinzaine quinzaine qui est le plus
proche de bonnes réponses la bonne
réponse ses 14 stations
mais j'ai quand même donné quelques
indications oui vous l'avez des
pensionnés ses 30 points pour lui tu
vois là c'est 50 20
bon j'arrête à la troisième et dernière
question est ce que je pourrais vous
présenter cette vidéo on parlait des
gens qui faisait le show il ya des gens
aussi qui ont tenté la traversée
c'est beaucoup plus grâce à la traversée
dans la direction transversale pas la
direction normal verticale mais
horizontale horizontale c'est ça alors
on a la vidéo numéro je sais que je suis
là combien la sévère quand les gens
regardent faut être sérieux numéro 5
vous êtes prêt technicien super alors 5
ans on regarde ça ça se passe en 2012 et
c'est un funambule américain une comme
une famille très bien connu les vallées
n'da il s'appelle nick valensi
il traverse sur un câble métallique la
chute du cher à cheval donc la chute
canadienne et il est le premier homme à
avoir marché sur la lune non sur une
corde raide fraude ou sinon oui je peux
raconter de sonneries dieu si il était
cependant il ya un filet de sécurité en
dessous de lui vous le voyez pas mais
s'était imposée par la bbc la chaîne de
télévision nbc qui filmait le tout et ça
a été vu en direct comme ça cette
traversée de 550 mètres qui a duré 25
minutes
trente huit mille spectateurs côté
américain mais beaucoup plus du côté
canadien les gens qui étaient présents
sur le sol
cent vingt mille canadiens qui étaient
là ce jour là ce soir là en fait
et puis à l'aide à la télévision 16
millions de téléspectateurs au total
j'ai enlevé le sont pas ce qu'on entend
des gens crier des abominations
[Musique]
mais dans le fond il faisait tout ça
juste pour épater la galerie où ben oui
parce que c'est ça comme ça qui gagne sa
vie il fait d une série d'exploits il
traverse entre deux édifices son père
est décédé comme ça je pense que c'était
au pérou c'était en amérique du sud
entre deux tours aucune vous savez c'est
par là ça vous rassure fait que son père
était décédé comme ça en faisant une
tentative similaire sans filet voilà
ceci nous mène la troisième et dernière
manche êtes prêts je pense qu'on va
regarder pour cette troisième manche
parce qu'il faut pour montrer des images
ici superbe c'est pas la chute la chute
ne sait comment ça s'appelle en
argentine uar souci c'est pas ça
malheureusement mais c'est 6 est
comparable
est ce que c'est un langues autochtones
il savait ça doit être doux victoria
numéro 6 les chutes victoria
sur la vidéo c'est en afrique du sud
c'est très bien et à part ceux dans quel
pays victoria est ce qu'on est payés du
commonwealth au zimbabwe bravo combien
de points il a déjà passé à la question
ça la question
j'ai pas encore fait qu'on vient
d'émettre de docu big il tombe pas c'est
presque ça c'est parce que ça me fait
c'est ça la question non voici au delà
de leur beauté les chutes de victoria
sont souvent comparés aux chutes niagara
parce que c'est à peu près le même écran
de même c'est beau c'est magnifique
figuration les joueurs on veut savoir où
je voudrais savoir il est tout le monde
à savoir d'ailleurs aussi ces chutes est
ce qu'elles sont les chutes victoria ce
qu'elles sont deux fois plus petit que
les chutes niagara au moins où est-ce
qu'ils sont au moins deux fois plus
grande
deux fois plus petit vous dites les
chutes victoria sont deux fois plus
petit que les chutes niagara aussi plus
grande
pourquoi au moins deux fois plus grande
deux fois plus grande
ouais mais vous voyez là les images ce
qui est deux fois plus grand et deux
fois plus grand ce qui est deux fois
plus petites salles mais c'est pour ça
que mais oui mais ce n'est pas donné
toute la réponse je vois paris c'est
pourquoi on n'a pas une vue panoramique
il vous permet de mieux apprécier ce qui
aurait été encore mieux c'est une vue à
la même altitude peu qu'on puisse
comparer c'est ça oui c'est pas possible
ça sans qu'il me suis dit qu'est ce
qu'on y est on dit que les chutes
victoria sont au moins deux fois plus
grande que les chenilles non seulement
en termes de longueur en termes de débit
c'est en terme d'ebitda corps mieux les
chutes victoria 9000 mètres cubes à la
seconde en période de pluies et puis
niagara 2800 mètres donc beaucoup plus
d'eau passe par là même trois fois plus
pis là je vous montre si vous voulez des
images des oiseaux à 1 me mais les deux
vidéos c'est extraordinaire au civc à la
c on s'en va plus loin mais je vais vous
montrer
c'est la même c'est vraiment important
coc également entre deux pays que moi
mais en fait laissé là c'est pas ces
parties de la triple frontière en savoie
il ya une côte est baissier côté
argentine puis jeu le paraguay est très
proche de là est-ce qu'il ya plein de
touristes qui vont si c'est vrai mais
viennent de partout la plus
sensationnelle que les chutes niagara je
dis pas ce que je fais à l'antenne de
radio canada international
mais c'est vraiment extraordinaire
piètre parcours c'est la même chose en
fait on peut aller en hélicoptères aussi
pour voir les shooteurs tiens je sais
pas il ya eu ça fait deux trois ans il
ya eu un monte dès la quantité d'eau
puis arracher toutes les façades elle
c'était vraiment un désastre mais ces
endroits pour tourner le film y en a en
fait le film qui est interprétée pour le
l'italie ni talent aux américains avec
les qui fait tout de la mafia c'est la
quatrième manche je sais quoi le film
qui se tâtent âge vous vous retrouvez
les noms magnifique ccc comme ils disent
au québec c'est épeurant
c'est écoeurant ah oui seigneur écoute
et veut dire tout autre chose dans un
autre contexte on veut regarder les
sujets qu'on a notre meilleur à offrir
cette semaine bien sûr ces démissions au
tam-tam may hamm et plus encore il ya
nos trois sujets qui sont sur la page
web de tam-tam canada et puis on va
aller dans notre à la fin de notre page
ici notre page technique de diffusion
la technique oui de la technique mais
les ceux qui nous regardent sur le web
non pas la page techniques mais ils ont
quand même accès à ces trois voilà nous
voici notre offre
cette somme est d'accord tout le monde
peut voir ça sur le web comme ici en
studio est allé sont à choisir votre
meilleur cette semaine c'est le stress
psychologique chez les médecins
oui en fait il se trouve que les
médecins comme les patients aussi ont
besoin de soins parce que c'est des
personnes qui travaillent beaucoup et
qui des fois non pas toujours les
ressources qu'il faut pour pouvoir bien
faire leur travail et du coup ils se
retrouvent stressé malades et ils ont
besoin dead et c'est une question qui a
été au centre de préoccupations lors
d'une réunion
à winnipeg où des experts se sont
penchés sur la question pour essayer
d'analyser c'est quoi le problème et
tenter de proposer des pistes de
solution
voilà donc il faut plus de financements
dans le réseau et puis il faut une
meilleure collaboration entre différents
corps pour pouvoir résoudre résorber ce
problème qui touche près de la moitié
des médecins aussi bien au canada qu'aux
états unis c'est ce que dit votre titre
en fait plus de la moitié des médecins
oui et cette histoire des problèmes de
santé dans les soins de santé
ici au québec on est beaucoup question
puisqu'on est en période électorale
c'est d'ailleurs le premier sujet notre
de notre meilleur cette semaine ça a été
réalisée par marie jobin qui dit les
quintes deux candidats issus de la
diversité durant la campagne électorale
québécoise sont en augmentation
durant cette campagne elle vous propose
une entrevue avec quelqu'un qui s'y
intéressent de très près c'est à suivre
dans l'actualité bien sûr québécoise et
puis bien l'autre question c'est
toujours lié aux élections c'est
facebook twitter et les promesses de
baisser de faire échec aux fausses
nouvelles le gouvernement canadien qui
veut également adopté une loi c'est 76
cet automne pour trouver une façon
d'éviter que des des opérateurs russes
investissent rester ici sur le web et
les électeurs gros sujet de conversation
dans les élections québécoises également
répartie qui se demandent qui va
manipuler quoi et comment
voilà ça c'est pour ce qui se passe dans
l'actualité c'est beaucoup plus très
bien si les élections en province et en
même temps ou même jour nous tout à fait
rare et puis n'oublions pas de parler de
cette démission fracassante au parti
conservateur du canada
le départ de maxime bernier qui a été
vivement critiquée par l'ensemble des
membres du parti conservateur qui estime
qu il rend service à justin trudeau
je sais pas ce que vous en pensez vous
c'est sur la question il faudrait
expliquer le dossier sur la question du
multiculturalisme de l'entrée des
migrants au canada et de la gestion de
l'offre aussi ouais
oui tout ça beaucoup de choses sont
beaucoup de dossiers coûter c'est un
petit peu on va on va perdre dans une
île
c'est foutu j'ai trouvé le film
s'appelle mission la mission aux saveurs
de niro avant clean
ils ont fait ils ont filmé grand passé
dans les choux
bon alors on continue notre cinéma la
semaine prochaine bien sûr ce fut un
plaisir de vous avoir ici pour parler de
cette ce bijou tout essais canadiens et
en faisant la recherche ne s'aperçut
qu'à radio-canada international afin qu
reportage en six ans sur ces chutes et à
la du canada aussi là la production est
assez pauvre en relation avec
l'importance que ces jeux ta coupe dans
le budget touristique canadien dans le
sait la seat l'attraction numéro 1
canadienne
ça dépasse le parc national de banff ou
jasper est canadien merci donc à chantal
alice chantal john holmes cette semaine
qui vous remercie
alors qui a gagné le quiz cette semaine
les marques félicitations mars puis à
léo ce fut un beau combat
alors ici stéphane parent et toute
l'équipe à la semaine prochaine